From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life.
来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》。
[DIALING]
[拨号音]
Ira Glass is off this week. I'm Sean Cole.
艾拉·格拉斯这周休假。我是肖恩·科尔。
Yo, Sean! This is your mom. I wasn't home.
哟，肖恩！我是你妈。我没在家。
I'm just going to say up front that today's show deals with a device invented more than a century ago to facilitate real time voice-to-voice interaction. The kids don't use it much for that purpose anymore, but in all the stories you're going to hear, the phone's primary purpose is as a phone.
我先直说，今天的节目内容涉及一种发明于一个多世纪前、旨在促进实时语音交互的设备。现在的孩子们不太用它来干这个了，但在你们将要听到的所有故事中，电话的主要目的依然是作为电话使用。
About four or five years ago, I started saving all my mom's voicemails, thinking, she's not going to be around forever. I'm going to want to hear her voice when she's gone. Though somehow I didn't extend that thought to, "I could hear her voice right now if I picked up the phone." She had a talent for the form. With some of them, it almost feels like I'm talking to her, except she's playing both parts.
大约四五年前，我开始保存我妈妈所有的语音留言，心想，她不会永远陪着我。等她不在了，我会想听她的声音。虽然不知为何我没想到“如果我接起电话，现在就能听到她的声音”。她在这一方面很有天赋。听着其中的一些留言，感觉就像在和她交谈，只不过是她一个人分饰两角。
What time is it? Oh, it's 6:52. Yeah, it's later than I thought. I can't believe it's still light out. Decided to go to the Royal for supper tonight. So that's what we did. We went early, and we are back early. So I don't know what you're doing. So this is me, c'est moi. I'm here. Right. Yo aqui.
几点了？噢，6点52了。是啊，比我想的要晚。真不敢相信天还没黑。决定今晚去皇家餐厅吃晚饭。所以我们就这么做了。我们去得早，回来得也早。我不知道你在干什么。总之这是我，就是我（法语）。我就在这儿。对。我就在这儿（西班牙语）。
C'est moi. It's me in French. Sometimes there's not much more than that.
“就是我”（法语）。在法语里是“C'est moi”。有时候意思也就仅此而已。
C'est moi. Love you much. Talk to you soon. Bye.
就是我。很爱你。回头再聊。拜拜。
This one's even shorter.
这个更短。
C'est moi. Bye.
就是我。拜拜。
But of course all the messages boil down to her saying, in one creative way or another, "Please call me back." Sometimes she was a lot more direct about it.
但当然，所有的留言归根结底都是在用各种有创意的方式说：“请回我电话。”有时候她会直接得多。
Don't forget to call your mother! Goodbye!
别忘了给你妈打电话！再见！
Actually, here's the one that I always tell people about when I'm talking about her messages. It's like she sort of circles and then goes in for the kill.
其实，每当我和别人聊起她的留言时，我都会提这一条。感觉她就像先兜圈子，然后再切入正题。
I heard you on the radio on Sunday, and I knew it was you, because I could recognize your voice, even though it's been a long time since I've heard it on the phone. So anyway, I love you lots and lots. Call me when you think of it, if you ever do. Love you. Bye.
周日我在收音机里听到了你的声音，我就知道是你，因为我能认出你的声音，尽管我已经很久没在电话里听过了。总之，我很爱你。想到的话就给我打电话，如果你能想到的话。爱你。拜拜。
My mom, her name was Pat. She died on September 28, 2015, At 4:22 in the morning. It was relatively sudden and totally unexpected. And as much as I thought I was preparing myself for that moment, I wasn't prepared. It's true, I didn't call enough. But she was still the first person I thought to call when something huge happened. Good or bad.
我妈，她叫帕特。她死于2015年9月28日凌晨4点22分。这件事发生得相当突然，完全出乎意料。尽管我觉得自己已经为那一刻做好了心理准备，但我并没有。确实，我打给她的电话不够多。但当发生大事时，无论好坏，她依然是我第一个想到要拨通电话的人。
I loved talking to her. She was funny, as you can tell. And smart. She wrote technical manuals in the early days of personal computing. Later in life, she lugged a lot of pro-grade camera equipment around the world, taking pictures. And yet she had a hard time figuring out her smartphone. The last recording I have from her saved on my phone, it was a pocket dial.
我喜欢和她聊天。正如你所听到的，她很幽默。而且很聪明。她在个人计算的早期编写技术手册。晚年，她背着很多专业级的摄影器材环游世界，到处拍照。然而，她却很难搞定自己的智能手机。我手机里保存的她最后一段录音，是一个误触拨出的口袋电话。
[POCKET DIALING]
[口袋误拨]
This goes on for three minutes.
这段录音持续了三分钟。
Did you go for your walk this morning?
你今天早上散步了吗？
No, I didn't make it this morning. I figured that I was pretty busy.
没，我今天早上没去成。我想我太忙了。
After mom died, I started calling home a lot more to talk to my stepdad, Ed Hacker. He and I never really had a phone relationship when my mother was alive. It was more the classic thing of, "You wanna say hi to Ed?" And then we'd verbally clap each other on the back, and then back to mom. These days, it's not weird for us to spend almost two hours on the phone together.
妈妈去世后，我开始更频繁地打回家和我继父埃德·哈克聊天。妈妈在世时，我和他之间并没有真正的电话往来。通常都是很经典的那种场景：“你想跟埃德打个招呼吗？”然后我们会在口头上互相客气一下，接着又转回和妈妈通话。现在，我们俩在电话里聊上近两个小时也不是什么怪事了。
Then I had to get tweets out, so--
然后我得发推文，所以——
You are the most active octogenarian on Twitter that I know about.
你是我所认识的推特上最活跃的八旬老人。
Well, I try to send out about six or seven tweets.
嗯，我尽量发六七条推文。
What did you send this morning?
你今天早上发了什么？
Oh, I said about three or four.
噢，我发了三四条吧。
I think of how annoyed my mom would be if she knew this, but I'm now performing the exact telephone behavior she wanted from me when she was around, except now with Ed. I call about once a week on average. And it's always me initiating the calls now.
我想到如果妈妈知道这一切会有多恼火，但我现在表现出的正是她生前所期望我展现的电话往来行为，只不过对象换成了埃德。我平均每周打一次电话。现在发起通话的人总是我。
At first, of course, it was mainly to make sure he was holding up OK, and to make sure I was holding up OK. But even now, when I miss a week, it eats at me, like I'm thinking, "Gotta call Ed, gotta call Ed." It's like an injustice that he's getting this treatment and not her, and I keep trying to square it somehow. But when I put this to Ed, he basically said it's really not that big a mystery.
起初，当然主要是为了确保他一切都好，也确保我自己一切都好。但即使是现在，如果我错过了这一周，心里就会很难受，就像在想：“得给埃德打电话，得给埃德打电话。”如果他得到了这种待遇而她却没有，这似乎很不公平，我一直在试图以某种方式寻求平衡。但当我把这个问题抛给埃德时，他基本上说这其实没什么大不了的。
Kind of obvious that if one parent dies, you realize that the other one may not be that far off, that he will go too, or she. So you know, the scarcity, just like in economics, makes the value go up.
很明显，如果一位父母去世了，你会意识到另一位可能也离你不远了，他或她也会离开。所以，就像经济学中那样，稀缺性会让价值上升。
I never thought of this in economic terms before.
我以前从没想过用经济学术语来理解这个问题。
Well, it's true of many things. If the population is very low--
嗯，这适用于很多事情。如果人口非常稀少——
Ed's 87. He taught philosophy and logic at a university in Boston for a lot of years. Which is fitting, because Ed is very logical and philosophical. He's always quoting one or another great thinker. For fun, he does math. He and my mom got together when I was six. He moved in when I was 11. And I think he's right that I call because I'm more aware than ever that one day he won't be on the other end of the phone, but it's more than that too.
埃德87岁了。他在波士顿的一所大学教了很多年哲学和逻辑学。这很贴切，因为埃德非常有逻辑且富有哲理。他总是引用某位伟大的思想家的名言。他把数学当娱乐。我和妈妈在一起时，我六岁。我11岁时他搬进来住。我想他是对的，我打电话是因为我比以往任何时候都更清楚，总有一天他不会再在电话的另一端了，但也不仅仅是这样。
Even though we have all of these other people in our family, whom we love, it got to feeling like Ed's the other one mom's death happened to, like he and I were the ones who mutually needed to talk about mom, and to hear about her.
尽管我们家庭中还有其他我们深爱的人，但感觉就像埃德是妈妈去世后的另一个受影响者，就像他和我是唯一能共同谈论妈妈、听听关于她的往事的人。
I feel that, yes, I could talk to you about Pat, because you're willing to talk to her about it.
我感觉得到，是的，我可以和你谈论帕特，因为你愿意谈论她。
To you about it, yeah.
跟你谈这些，是的。
And it makes a big difference to me.
这对我有很大意义。
It does?
真的吗？
Of course.
当然。
I'm so glad to hear that.
听到这话我真高兴。
Because you lost the same person. Even if it's somewhat similar if somebody else has lost someone else, you know, these groups in which everyone has lost a spouse, and their memories are different. You know you never met the other person that died. You really don't care.
因为你失去了同一个人。即使当别人失去了其他人时情况有些相似，你知道，这些每个人都失去了配偶的群体，他们的记忆是不同的。你永远没有见过那个去世的另一个人。你真的不在乎。
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
You care about your loss. You know, be honest.
你在乎的是你自己的损失。你知道，诚实点。
Are you on the deck now?
你现在在甲板上吗？
I am.
我在。
Having a smoke?
在抽烟？
I am.
我在。
For a long time, my mom was a third invisible person in all of these conversations. And it feels weird to say this, but in some ways, it's like I've gotten to know her better from talking to Ed. And I'm clearer now on what her very last days on earth were like. But we've both noticed we're talking about mom less and less.
很长一段时间里，妈妈就像所有这些对话中看不见的第三个人。说这话感觉很奇怪，但在某些方面，通过和埃德交谈，我感觉自己更了解她了。我现在也更清楚她在这世上最后的日子是怎么度过的。但我们俩都注意到，谈论妈妈的次数越来越少了。
People told me this would happen, but I didn't really believe them. Or I didn't want to. Time slouches on. You wake up to different thoughts in the morning. And when you call home the first thing you say isn't, "How are you holding up?" Like, it used to be that you would mark how long it had been. You'd say like, "I can't believe it'll be three months on Monday," or, "I can't believe it'll be nine months on Thursday or whatever."
人们告诉我这会发生，但我并不真的相信他们。或者我不想相信。时间在缓慢流逝。你早上醒来时会想到不同的事情。当你给家里打电话时，第一句话不再是“你还好吗？”就像以前一样，你会记录下已经过了多久。你会说“真不敢相信周一就三个月了”或者“真不敢相信周四就九个月了”之类的。
Well, I still keep track of the time.
嗯，我仍然会记录时间。
You do?
你有吗？
Yeah, and I also have an app on my computer, all three of them, which is set to tell me how many days since Pat died.
有，而且我在电脑上还有个应用程序，设置了三个，告诉我帕特去世多少天了。
You do?
真的吗？
I do.
是的。
Oh, I didn't know that.
噢，我不知道。
So this way, I'm going there right now, to see what my apps are. What do they call it now? Got too much junk here.
所以我现在正打算去看看我的应用程序。现在叫什么来着？这里垃圾太多了。
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
Oh yes, Count Down. You can set it for anything, you know. I mean-- well, it's been 22 months and three days since she's died. Or if you want, one year, 10 months, and three days. Or if you want, 95-- 96 weeks.
噢对了，倒计时。你可以设置任何东西，你知道的。我是说……嗯，离她去世已经22个月零3天了。或者如果你想要的话，是一年10个月零3天。或者，96周。
And what do you feel like, looking at that?
看着那个，你有什么感觉？
Don't have any particular feeling. It's just that it's amazing that it's almost two years. It's like saying I remember.
没什么特别的感觉。只是觉得快两年了真是不可思议。这就像是在说我记得。
Yeah, I feel like I need something like that. I just feel like I don't think about her enough.
是啊，我觉得我也需要类似的东西。只是觉得自己想她的不够多。
Well, that you'll have to explain. Why should you think more?
嗯，这个你得解释一下。为什么你应该多想她？
I don't know. It's just like--
我不知道。就是觉得……
Is it guilt or something?
是因为内疚吗？
It's not guilt, no.
不是内疚，不是。
You want to honor her more by thinking about her?
你想通过多想她来纪念她？
Yeah, I want to honor her more by thinking about her, and it also feels like there's something going on in me all the time that I'm not acknowledging, that kind of leaks out in these other ways. And I just miss her. And so it's like I need to put that missing somewhere.
是的，我想通过多想她来纪念她，而且也觉得我内心深处总有什么东西没被承认，以其他方式泄露了出来。我只是想她。所以就像是我需要把这种思念安放好。
Well, you have a photograph of Pat?
嗯，你有帕特的照片吗？
Yeah, I have one up on the wall in my office.
有，我办公室墙上挂着一张。
OK, take another one. And every day, move it from one spot to another in your apartment.
好的，再拿一张。每天在你的公寓里把它从一个地方移到另一个地方。
That's a really good idea. Did you just think of that?
这主意真不错。你是刚想到的吗？
Yes. That makes it sort of a ritual.
是的。这让它变成了一种仪式。
But the truth is, I already have the ritual I need. I don't do it every day, but I do it just about every week. I call Ed. We talk. For this specific need I have, it turns out he's the perfect person to call. Maybe you've got somebody like that, a personal Ghostbuster when there's something strange in the neighborhood, when things are looking their worst, that person who will know what you're talking about, even if they can't understand what you're saying. And all you've gotta do is call.
但事实是，我已经有了我需要的仪式。我不是每天都做，但我几乎每周都做。我给埃德打电话。我们交谈。对于我这种特殊的需求，事实证明他是最完美的对象。也许你也有这样一个人，当周围出现异常，当事情看起来最糟糕时，你的私人捉鬼敢死队，那个即使听不懂你在说什么，也知道你在说什么的人。你所要做的就是打电话。
Our show today in three area codes is about people lucky enough to find someone like that, in some very dire situations, and also when they need directions to Garbage Street. It's really called that. Stay with us.
我们今天的节目在三个区号范围内，讲述的是那些足够幸运，能在某些极其可怕的情况下找到这样一个人，或者在需要去“垃圾街”问路时找到这样一个人的人们。那条街真的叫这个名字。请继续收听。
Act 1, Fass Talker. There's this legendary late night radio show host on WBAI here in New York named Bob Fass. And he hosts a show called Radio Unnameable. It first went on the air in 1963, and it was Bob's idea. He told the station managers he wanted to talk to all the late shift workers and the other night owls who were up at that hour.
第一幕，口若悬河。纽约的WBAI电台有一位传奇的深夜电台主持人，名叫鲍勃·法斯。他主持一档名为《无名电台》的节目。该节目于1963年首次播出，这是鲍勃的主意。他告诉电台经理，他想和所有的晚班工人和那些在那个钟点还没睡的夜猫子们聊天。
This is Bob Fass, and this is Radio Unnameable.
我是鲍勃·法斯，这里是《无名电台》。
He goes on at midnight, keeps listeners company until dawn. For a while, it aired five or six nights a week, but ultimately the station scaled it back to Thursday nights. WBAI is a listener-funded community station. It's part of the Pacifica Foundation. And when Radio Unnameable started, it was the kind of 1960s, 1970s radio show that really doesn't exist anymore. If Bob liked a song, he might play it over and over again all night. Or he'd play two songs at once.
他从午夜开始播出，陪伴听众直到黎明。有一段时间，它每周播出五六个晚上，但最终电台将其缩减到了周四晚上。WBAI是一个由听众资助的社区电台。它是太平洋基金会的一部分。当《无名电台》开播时，它是那种现在已经不复存在的六七十年代电台节目。如果鲍勃喜欢一首歌，他可能会整晚反复播放。或者他会同时播放两首歌。
Famous musicians like Bob Dylan would drop by after midnight. Sometimes, they performed. And sometimes, Bob would put a ton of people on the phone all at once.
像鲍勃·迪伦这样的著名音乐家会在午夜后顺道拜访。有时，他们会表演。有时，鲍勃会同时接通很多人的电话。
There's snow out there.
外面下雪了。
Snow?
雪？
Snow.
雪。
Where.
哪里。
Trees.
树上。
This audio is from a documentary movie about Bob's show. The movie is also called Radio Unnameable.
这段音频来自一部关于鲍勃节目的纪录片。这部电影也叫《无名电台》。
Is there snow?
真的有雪吗？
Yeah, there's snow.
嗯，有雪。
Oh.
噢。
Where have you been?
你刚才在哪儿？
Oh, wait a minute.
噢，等一下。
Open your eyes and look outside. There's snow.
睁开眼看看外面。有雪。
Nope, not on 60th. It's as dry as a bone. Where are you?
没，60号街没有。干得像根骨头。你在哪儿？
I'm on 66th.
我在66号街。
No snow on 60th. I swear it.
60号街没雪。我发誓。
Must be an underprivileged street.
那准是一条贫民区街道。
A lot of people have felt like Bob Fass was the perfect person to call, when they were alone in the middle of the night.
很多人都觉得在深夜独自一人时，鲍勃·法斯是最好的通话对象。
Bob, you just missed a good conversation.
鲍勃，你刚刚错过了一段精彩的对话。
And the story I'm going to tell you is about just one caller for whom that was certainly true. This call came in to WBAI on November 6, 1971, about a quarter to 3:00 in the morning.
我要讲的这个故事是关于一个确实如此的听众。这通电话是在1971年11月6日凌晨3点前大约一刻钟打进WBAI的。
BAI.
BAI电台。
Oh, it certainly takes you long enough.
噢，你们接通得可真慢。
Bob and the caller talked for 45 minutes. This is minute one.
鲍勃和听众聊了45分钟。这是第一分钟。
Are you a gentlemen? I hope.
你是个绅士吗？我希望是。
I don't know what a gentleman means.
我不知道绅士意味着什么。
Well, I'm in the process of committing suicide, and maybe this would help BAI, you know, to collect money or something.
嗯，我正在自杀的过程中，也许这能帮到BAI，你知道，筹集点钱什么的。
Just a quick trigger warning for people who are sensitive to hearing about suicide, that's what this call is about.
给那些对自杀内容敏感的听众一个快速的预警，这通电话就是关于这个的。
But don't turn me in or ... my number or anything like that.
但是别报警，或者……查我的号码什么的。
You're in the process of committing suicide.
你正在自杀的过程中。
That's a crime.
那是犯罪。
That voice there is another guy who was in the studio with Bob that night. Even Bob doesn't remember who it was anymore. It was a long time ago.
那个声音是那天晚上和鲍勃在演播室里的另一个人。连鲍勃都不记得他是谁了。那是很久以前的事了。
That's a what.
那是啥？
And here Bob kind of shushes his friend.
鲍勃在这里示意他的朋友安静。
Don't answer that.
别回答那个。
A crime? All my life I've wanted to commit a crime. At last, I succeeded.
犯罪？我这辈子都想犯一次罪。终于，我成功了。
Why? I mean, why did you call up to say that you were going to commit suicide?
为什么？我是说，你为什么要打来电话说你要自杀？
Because you might be able to use this in some way.
因为你可能能以某种方式利用它。
How can I use it?
我怎么利用它？
I see it as an item on page 3 of tomorrow's New York Post, you know? "Suicide calls BA--."
我把它看作明天《纽约邮报》第三页的一条新闻，你知道吗？“自杀者拨打BAI电台——”
Apparently, the caller says a cussword at this point. They had to censor it.
显然，听众在此时说了一个脏话。他们不得不进行消音处理。
All right. Hey, that's really funny. Like, you say you're going to commit suicide, and now I have to bleep you off the air.
好吧。嘿，那真是太搞笑了。你说你要自杀，现在我得把你消音。
How do you mean, "Off the air?"
你说的“取消播出”是什么意思？
Well, you said you said a word that you can't say on the air, even if you are about to depart this vale of tears.
好吧，你说了个广播里不能说的词，哪怕你即将告别这个泪水之谷。
I am.
是的。
You are, huh? Why? I mean--
你要离开了，嗯？为什么？我是说——
... of things, including a final rejection from a girlfriend, trite as all that.
……各种事情，包括被女朋友彻底拒绝，尽管这听起来很陈词滥调。
Well, that'll really teach her, won't it?
嗯，那真是能给她一个教训，不是吗？
Teach her or me?
教训她还是教训我？
Her. Well, it'll teach you, I guess.
她。嗯，我想是教训你。
Teach me. Yeah, she'll be around for a while.
教训我。是的，她还会再待一阵子的。
If you listen closely, you can hear a sort of hushed hubbub in the background. Bob's writing a note to get people's attention. It wasn't long before other staff at the station were calling the police, who in turn started working with the phone company to see if they could track the guy down. All the while, Bob stays surprisingly collected.
如果你仔细听，能听到背景中有一种低声的骚乱。鲍勃正在写字条引起人们的注意。没过多久，电台的其他工作人员就开始报警，警方转而与电话公司合作，试图追踪那个人。自始至终，鲍勃都保持着令人惊讶的冷静。
I hope you're not, you know, doing anything about tracing the call.
我希望你们没有，你知道，在做任何追踪电话的事。
Well I don't know. Suppose I was?
嗯，我不知道。假设我在做呢？
I wouldn't want you to.
我不希望你们那样做。
Well, suppose I said I didn't want you to commit suicide? What do you care what I want?
嗯，假设我说我不希望你自杀呢？你干嘛在乎我想要什么？
I would appreciate the thought.
我会感激你的想法。
All right, well, I don't. I mean, I think it's a-- if you think you're going to die of a broken heart, you're not--
好吧，但我不在乎。我是说，我觉得这——如果你认为你会心碎而死，那你不会——
The truth is that my life is in a total mess at the moment, both as far as jobs, my girlfriend, my so-called friends.
事实是我的生活目前一团糟，无论是工作、女朋友，还是我所谓的那些朋友。
How are you gonna do it?
你打算怎么做？
I've done it, I'm sorry to say.
我已经做了，很遗憾。
What do you mean?
你什么意思？
I've taken an amalgam of pills.
我吃了一种混合药片。
What have you taken?
你吃了什么？
Sleeping pills. Three different kinds of sleeping pills and some anti-depressants. And I think the totality of it will do it. At least, I hope so.
安眠药。三种不同的安眠药和一些抗抑郁药。我觉得总量应该足够了。至少，我希望如此。
I'm going to tell you right now that the caller survived. In fact, he lived for another 20 years after this. Which means he died when he was 68. I can't find any record of how he died. But I'm telling you this in part because I don't want that question to distract you from how this phone call played out.
我在这里直接告诉你，那位听众活了下来。事实上，他在那之后又活了20年。这意味着他在68岁时去世了。我找不到任何关于他死因的记录。但我告诉你这些，部分原因是我不想让这个问题转移你对这通电话如何发展的注意力。
I've really never heard anything like it. I feel like a lot of times, in stories like this, the people trying to stop a potential suicide victim tiptoe around that person gingerly, careful not to make any sudden moves. Bob didn't do that. He didn't treat the guy like a potential victim. He treated him like a person, like anybody else calling into the show. And to be a person with someone who's about to cease being a person, that just takes an awful lot of nerve.
我真的从没听过类似的事情。我觉得在很多这样的故事里，试图阻止潜在自杀受害者的人会小心翼翼，生怕有什么突发举动。鲍勃没那样做。他没把那个人当作潜在的受害者。他把他当作一个人，就像任何打进电话的人一样。而与一个即将不再是“人”的人作为“人”去沟通，这需要极大的勇气。
At first, I thought it was a gag.
起初，我以为这是个恶作剧。
I went out to Bob's house on Staten Island to talk to him about this call, ask him what he remembers. Which is not a ton, but certain things have stuck with him. He says WBAI had been doing a fundraising marathon that night, and the calls were all coming into the pledge room. He thought maybe the caller was just trying to get on the air and said this crazy thing to make sure they'd patch him through.
我去史坦顿岛鲍勃家和他聊了这通电话，问他记得什么。他记得的不多，但有些事一直留在脑海里。他说那天晚上WBAI在进行筹款马拉松，所有的电话都打进了认捐室。他想或许那个听众只是想上电台，才说了这种疯狂的话以确保能被转接。
You ever heard the expression "a dead baby call?"
你听过“死婴电话”这个说法吗？
No.
没有。
Talk show language. In the middle of a happy time, someone calls up and says, "My baby just died." A wet blanket call.
脱口秀术语。在大家开心的时候，有人打电话来说：“我的孩子刚死了。”这是一个泼冷水的电话。
I see.
我明白了。
But when his speech began to slur, it didn't seem like a typical call like that.
但当他的话开始含糊不清时，这看起来不像那种典型的电话。
Do you know what? It's not because I don't trust you. I'm going to hang up.
你知道吗？不是因为我不相信你。我要挂了。
Well, wait a minute, wait a minute, wait a minute. The worst thing that can happen is somebody will stop you from doing this thing, and then you'll have another chance to do it later. Talk to me for a few--
嗯，等一下，等一下，等一下。最坏的情况也就是有人阻止你，然后你以后还有机会。和我聊几——
I've dispersed my estate, so to speak.
我已经分配了我的财产，可以这么说。
He says, "I've dispersed my estate, so to speak." Meaning, he sent what little was left in his checking account to a handful of friends.
他说：“我已经分配了我的财产，可以这么说。”意思是，他把自己支票账户里剩下的那点钱寄给了几个朋友。
I'd be very embarrassed to ask for the money back, you know.
要回这些钱会让我非常尴尬，你知道。
Well, maybe-- maybe it was in some way, it was all of your possessions that were hanging you up. You know?
嗯，也许——也许以某种方式，是所有的财产让你感到束缚。你知道吗？
With all due respect, I think you're trying to trick me, and I'm going to hang up. And I hope BAI can use this in some way. You know, it's dramatic and all that. You know.
恕我直言，我认为你在耍我，我要挂了。我希望BAI能以某种方式利用它。你知道，这很戏剧化等等。你知道。
Well, I mean, why do you want BAI to have the use of your death or your--
嗯，我是说，你为什么想让BAI利用你的死亡或者你的——
I've never had the decency to send you 15 bucks.
我从来没有良心发现给你们寄过15块钱。
I don't think you ought to kill yourself over it. I mean, a little guilt is OK.
我不认为你应该为此自杀。我是说，有点内疚是可以的。
I'm not killing myself over that. But you know, I've really never done anything for the station, and the station's a good station, and it's afforded me a lot of pleasure in a mostly otherwise drought-ridden life. And now I'm going to say goodbye.
我不是为此自杀。但是你知道，我确实从没为电台做过什么，这是一家好电台，它在我本来干旱枯燥的生活中给了我很多乐趣。现在我要说再见了。
Wait a minute, wait a minute. Before you say goodbye, give us like-- it takes about 20 minutes to trace a call, and you haven't been on the phone with us for three minutes yet.
等一下，等一下。在你告别之前，给我们点——追踪电话大约需要20分钟，你还没和我们通上三分钟呢。
You telling me the truth?
你跟我说实话吗？
I'm telling you the truth. It takes about 20 minutes to trace a call. I know, because we tried to--
我跟你说实话。追踪电话大约需要20分钟。我知道，因为我们试过——
Why does it take so long?
为什么需要那么久？
Because the telephone company is more messed up than your life is, and they're not about to commit suicide.
因为电话公司比你的生活更混乱，而且他们可不想自杀。
I guess I would have worried that like, oh no. Like, he's going to hang up. Do you know what I mean? I think that's why I would have been-- I would have been so gentle. Do you know what I mean?
我猜我会担心，噢不。我是说，他要挂了。你知道我的意思吗？我想这就是为什么我会——我会那么温柔。你知道我的意思吗？
Well, I thought I was trying to be gentle, but if you lull someone to sleep, that's what you're fighting against. If you can get them to show a little ire, maybe they'll hang on to life.
嗯，我以为我在试着温柔，但如果你让人睡着了，那就是你在对抗的东西。如果你能让他们表现出一点愤怒，也许他们会留恋生命。
I think we've been talking 20 minutes.
我想我们已经聊了20分钟了。
No, we haven't been talking 20--
不，我们没聊20——
15, at least.
至少15分钟。
What?
什么？
I have a good time sense. 15, at least.
我的时间感很好。至少15分钟。
I don't think so. I don't think it's been more than five.
我不这么认为。我不觉得超过五分钟。
Oh no, no. It's not five.
噢不，不。绝对不止五分钟。
It's eight. This is eight minutes in.
八分钟。这是第8分钟。
I think that the drugs are distorting your sense of time.
我觉得药物扭曲了你的时间感。
No, they're not.
不，没有。
That's the first thing.
那是第一点。
I have a very good time sense. We've been speaking 18 minutes.
我的时间感非常好。我们已经聊了18分钟了。
All right, I'll tell you what. As a test of that, I'll start and you tell me when a minute is up.
好吧，我告诉你怎么做。作为测试，我开始计时，你告诉我一分钟什么时候结束。
All right.
好吧。
I have a timer right here, and we'll-- it's an electronic timer.
我这儿有个计时器，我们——这是一个电子计时器。
You'll see that I'll be right within five seconds.
你会看到我误差在5秒以内。
OK, started now. All right, you tell me when a minute is up. OK, will you bet your life on your ability to do this?
好，现在开始。好了，你告诉我一分钟什么时候结束。好吗，你愿意拿你的生命赌你做这件事的能力吗？
No.
不。
No. See? You're not willing to gamble. You're afraid that something is going to happen to--
不。看到了吗？你不想赌。你害怕会发生什么——
I'm a gambler.
我是个赌徒。
What?
什么？
I am a gambler.
我是一个赌徒。
Well, then gamble on this. I mean, this is the ultimate bet of all, isn't it?
好吧，那赌这个吧。我是说，这是终极赌局，不是吗？
In one shape or another, that's been in my mind since I was 16 or younger.
以各种形式，从我16岁或更小的时候起，这个念头就在我脑海里了。
Well, I mean, I don't think that's even unique. I think everyone has had-- has been struggling against the awareness of death.
好吧，我是说，这甚至不是特例。我想每个人都在——都在与对死亡的意识做斗争。
Right there. There's the minute.
就在那儿。一分钟到了。
No, it's 45 seconds. You're 15 seconds off. And 15 seconds out of every minute--
不，才45秒。你差了15秒。而每分钟差15秒——
I was talking, so I got carried away maybe.
我在说话，所以可能分心了。
All right, let's see if you can do it in silence.
好吧，看看你在安静的时候能不能做到。
No, no, no. You're stalling me. You're obviously stalling me. I appreciate it a great deal.
不，不，不。你在拖延我。你显然在拖延我。我非常感激。
You're right. I am trying to stall you, and trying to talk you out of it. And I think you ought to give me half a chance.
你说得对。我是在拖延你，试图劝你放弃。我觉得你应该给我一个机会。
This is another remarkable thing about this phone call. The caller keeps saying, "I'm on to you. I've figured you out." But there's nothing to figure out. For the entire 45 minutes, Bob is scrupulously honest about what he's doing. This is one of the few times in life where it would be more than forgivable to mislead someone, to just keep stringing them along to keep them on the phone. And Bob never does that. Because he never did that on the air. As always, he's just a naked heart speaking into the microphone, which, in this situation, that's the ultimate bet.
这是这通电话另一个引人注目的地方。听众一直在说：“我看出你的把戏了。我识破你了。”但根本没什么可识破的。在这45分钟里，鲍勃对他所做的事情一丝不苟地诚实。这是人生中极少数可以被原谅去误导别人的时刻之一，只是为了留住他们，让他们待在电话线上。而鲍勃从不这样做。因为他在节目里从不那样做。像往常一样，他只是对着麦克风诉说着一颗赤诚之心，在这种情况下，这就是终极赌注。
I mean, you called me. You called us here because you wanted to say something to us, or to people listening, or do something for us.
我是说，是你打给我的。你打给我们是因为你想对我们，或者对收听的听众说点什么，或者为我们做点什么。
Yeah, get your PR department on this. You can use a little publicity and some money.
是的，让你们的公关部门来处理吧。你们可以利用点名声和钱。
I mean, I think that's insulting that we would use someone's death. Give us a chance to find out why, and tell us, convince us that it's a right and proper action.
我是说，我认为我们利用别人的死亡是种侮辱。给我们一个机会找出原因，告诉我们，说服我们这是一个正确且正当的行动。
All right. Let me ask you three questions. Please answer care--
好吧。让我问你三个问题。请小心回答——
I'll answer very carefully.
我会非常小心地回答。
What?
什么？
I'll answer very carefully.
我会非常小心地回答。
I don't care about carefully, but honestly.
我不关心小心不小心，我关心的是诚实。
You started to say "carefully." Didn't you start to say "carefully?"
你刚才开始说“小心地”，不是吗？
Yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊。
Well, I mean that stuff is important. I will answer carefully, and I will answer honestly.
好吧，我是说那些都很重要。我会小心地回答，也会诚实地回答。
Are we on the air?
我们在直播吗？
Yes, we are.
是的，我们在直播。
I'd rather be off. One, OK?
我宁愿不在直播。第一点，好吗？
You'd rather be off?
你宁愿不在直播？
Yeah.
是的。
OK.
好吧。
Off the air.... And two, I would like your promise that-- your sterling promise that you're not going to have this call traced. Do I have that?
停止播出……第二点，我想要你的承诺——你绝对的承诺，你不会去追踪这个电话。我有这个承诺吗？
[SIGHING]
[叹气]
It's a tough one, I know.
这是个难题，我知道。
It is a tough one. I mean, it's really like-- because you see what you've laid on me?
确实是难题。我是说，这真的像是——因为你看你给我出了什么难题？
I know. But I wasn't always this way.
我知道。但我以前不是这样的。
Yeah, but don't you see? I don't think you could get that promise out of any human being.
是啊，但你没看出来吗？我不认为你能从任何人那里得到那个承诺。
It was not easy to trace a call in 1971. And in this case, it took a lot longer than 20 minutes. The process is way too complicated to explain here, but it was a mechanical process that involved multiple people at the phone company's central office. And it may have already been under way by the time the caller asked for it not to be. In any case, it wasn't like Bob was doing it himself. And again, he could have said to the guy, "Sure, I won't trace it," just to appease him. But Bob says that didn't seem right.
在1971年追踪电话并不容易。在这种情况下，花费的时间远不止20分钟。这个过程过于复杂，无法在此解释，这是一个机械过程，涉及电话公司中央办公室的多人。而且当听众要求不要追踪时，它可能已经开始了。无论如何，这不像是鲍勃自己在做。再说一遍，他本可以对那个人说：“当然，我不会追踪，”只是为了安抚他。但鲍勃说那看起来不对。
This is a guy who might be dead. And if the last thing that someone told him was a lie, that's heavy. I didn't want to do that.
这是一个可能即将死去的人。如果一个人最后听到的东西是谎言，那太沉重了。我不想那样做。
I'd like to continue talking to you for a while.
我想继续和你聊一会儿。
All right, got but only with that promise that you're not going to have the call traced.
好吧，只有在我那个“你不追踪电话”的承诺下。
I can't promise that, but I mean, you can force me to, if you'll say that's the only way you'll talk to me. But it's not a promise that I want to make.
我无法保证这一点，但我可以这样说，你可以强迫我，如果你说那是你愿意和我谈的唯一方式。但这并不是我愿意做出的承诺。
I'll stop talking to you then, because I don't want to have a kind of messy night with a lot of beefy Irish policemen sitting at the foot of my bed.
那我就不和你谈了，因为我不想经历一个混乱的夜晚，床边坐着一大群魁梧的爱尔兰警察。
What have you got against the Irish?
你对爱尔兰人有什么意见？
Nothing. I rather like the Irish.
没有。我倒挺喜欢爱尔兰人的。
Yeah, we got a priest down here who'll talk to you too. He'll be up in a minute, sonny.
是啊，我们有个神父在这儿也能和你聊。他马上就上来，小伙子。
Around about the 20 minute mark, something weird happens. The conversation floats down to earth and becomes totally normal. Imagine for a second that this is where you came in, that you've heard nothing else up till now.
在大约20分钟处，发生了奇怪的事情。对话回到了地面，变得完全正常。想象一下，如果这是你刚加入的时候，到目前为止你还没听到其他内容。
I despise Orson Welles, but he's not himself in this movie.
我蔑视奥逊·威尔斯，但他在这部电影里不像他自己。
Why do you despise Orson Welles? Everybody digs it.
为什么你蔑视奥逊·威尔斯？大家都喜欢他。
I find him so hammy.
我觉得他太做作了。
Because of those airline commercials?
是因为那些航空公司的广告吗？
I don't know the airline commercial.
我不知道航空公司的广告。
He was great in Citizen Kane.
他在《公民凯恩》里表现很棒。
Yeah, I mean, no, I don't think so. I mean, I think that he may have been hammy throughout his career, but the hamminess has become him.
是啊，我是说，不，我不这么认为。我是说，我觉得他可能整个职业生涯都很做作，但那种做作已经成了他的一部分。
That's like an old Betty Field movie. Did you ever see that? It was called Tales of Manhattan.
那就像一部老贝蒂·菲尔德电影。你见过吗？叫《曼哈顿故事》。
Turns out the caller's a real movie buff. He works in media, writes satire, some humor. He's a freelancer. He and Bob dreamily run through one of the plotlines of an old Betty Field movie called Flesh and Fantasy.
事实证明，那位听众是个真正的电影迷。他在媒体工作，写讽刺文章，写幽默作品。他是自由撰稿人。他和鲍勃梦幻般地回顾了一部叫《肉体与幻想》的老贝蒂·菲尔德电影的情节。
This is what most of the calls on Radio Unnameable were like. Bob didn't screen them, and there was rarely a point to them. It sounded more like family catching up with each other. And by the way, this wasn't the first time that someone called up the show who was suicidal. Bob says a woman called once, threatening to kill herself, and he managed to talk her down. He says she's still around, doing OK.
《无名电台》里的大多数电话都是这样。鲍勃不筛选它们，也很少有目的性。这听起来更像家人在叙旧。顺便提一下，这并不是第一次有人打进节目说要自杀。鲍勃说有位女士曾打电话威胁要自杀，他设法劝住了她。他说她现在还在，过得挺好。
If someone is so lacking in friends and other human contacts that they need the voice that comes out of the radio to be their friend, they're really-- they're in trouble, you know? I mean, I can remember in my life when there were times that the only thing I could trust to the extent that I could trust it was the voice coming out of Long John or Jean Shepherd.
如果一个人极其缺乏朋友和其他人类联系，以至于他们需要收音机里发出的声音作为朋友，那他们真的——他们有麻烦了，你知道吗？我是说，我记得在我生命中，有些时候我唯一能信任的——只要能信任的程度——就是长约翰或吉恩·谢泼德电台里发出的声音。
These are radio personalities in your day?
这些是你那个时代的电台名人吗？
That's right. They had carved a place out of the universe that was reasonably sane for them.
没错。他们在宇宙中为自己开辟了一个相对理性的空间。
And they were overnight announcers too, Long John Nebel and Jean Shepherd. The difference is, they weren't exactly the kind of guys you'd call up when you'd already swallowed three kinds of pharmaceuticals. If this caller was looking for empathy, empathy is what Bob specialized in.
他们也是深夜广播员，长约翰·内贝尔和吉恩·谢泼德。不同之处在于，他们不是那种当你已经吞下了三种药物时会打给的家伙。如果这个听众是在寻求共鸣，鲍勃就是共鸣方面的专家。
25 minutes in, Bob seems to have gotten to the guy, in a good way. His guard is down. He's relaxed. He's also on a supreme amount of sedatives, so there's that. They're talking about the smallest little thing. The guy says he's drinking seltzer. Bob asks if it's one of those old fashioned Marx Brothers type bottles that you squirt. The caller says no.
25分钟后，鲍勃似乎成功地影响了那个人，往好的方向。他的防线已经放下。他很放松。他当时也服用了大量的镇静剂，所以有那一层因素。他们在谈论最小的事情。那个人说他在喝苏打水。鲍勃问那是不是那种老式的马克思兄弟电影里喷射的瓶子。听众说不是。
This is bad, but you can't get that on the East Side. There's a clue.
这很糟糕，但在东区你买不到那个。这是条线索。
"There's a clue," he says.
“这是条线索，”他说。
That's weird, that you can't get that on the East Side.
真奇怪，东区买不到那个。
Yeah, at least as far as I know, you can't. At least not on the Upper East Side.
是啊，至少我知道买不到。至少在上东区买不到。
I think you can. I think if you live in a neighborhood where the seltzer man isn't afraid of junkies jumping him in the hallway, you can get seltzer delivered. Doesn't that make you want to live?
我觉得可以买到。我觉得如果你住在苏打水小贩不怕瘾君子在走廊里跳出来袭击他的社区，你就能买到苏打水。这难道不让你想活下去吗？
Almost. It's not that I don't want to live. It's that I do want to die.
差不多。并不是我不想活。是我确实想死。
Why do you want to die?
你为什么想死？
Oh.
噢。
I mean, can you talk-- I mean, if dying is so hot, why don't you try to talk me into it?
我是说，你能聊聊——我是说，如果死那么好，你为什么不试着说服我死？
No, it has to be a very individual decision.
不，这必须是一个非常个人的决定。
All I ask you to do is to explain in a manner that I could understand why you were going to do yourself in, so that I would say, oh yeah, that's a logical decision.
我只要求你以我能理解的方式解释一下你为什么要自杀，这样我会说，噢对，那是合乎逻辑的决定。
Well, I'll try.
好吧，我试试。
He says, "Well, I'll try." But then he doesn't. What gets me the most about this whole call is the tone in Bob's voice during it. At the very same time he's being empathetic, he's also saying, "No, don't." It's one of the trickiest balancing acts you can try when relating to another person, something you usually only do when you've reached a bedrock level of intimacy with someone. And here he's doing it with a complete stranger. But Bob says there's a way in which he felt connected to the guy.
他说，“好吧，我试试。”但后来他没试。关于整通电话，最触动我的是鲍勃说话的语调。他在表示共鸣的同时，也在说：“不，别这样。”当你与他人交往时，这是你能尝试的最棘手的平衡行为之一，通常只有当你与某人达到了基石般的亲密关系时才会这样做。而在这里，他却对一个陌生人这样做了。但鲍勃说，他以某种方式感到了与那人的联系。
Without going into it too deeply, I had been severely depressed at one important point myself. And I recognized that it's possible to come back, you know? So--
不去深入探讨，我自己曾在某个重要时刻极度抑郁过。我知道回来是可能的，你知道吗？所以——
You could identify with that feeling.
你能认同那种感觉。
I could. Now you've gotten-- you gotten me a little agitated here.
我可以。现在你——你让我有点激动了。
Oh, I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
噢，我很抱歉。我很抱歉。
Well, it's nice to know you're alive.
嗯，知道你还活着真好。
At about minute 38, the caller starts to slip into that liminal space between waking and sleeping. His speech is so slurry it's almost incomprehensible. Like tape that's been slowed way down. He keeps talking, but you can tell he's starting to dream at the same time.
大约在38分钟时，听众开始滑入清醒与睡眠之间的边缘地带。他的话含糊不清，几乎听不懂。就像录音带被放慢了一样。他一直在说，但你能感觉到他同时开始做梦了。
Voices?
声音？
The kids.
孩子们。
The kids? What kids?
孩子们？什么孩子？
The kids--
孩子们——
Then he stops making sense.
然后他就不再逻辑清晰了。
Well, what did "the kids" mean? You said something about kids.
嗯，“孩子们”是什么意思？你刚才说了一些关于孩子的事。
Yeah, in Milano. In Milano.
是的，在米兰。在米兰。
In what?
什么？
Near-- near-- near Milano, a city in Italy.
在——在——在米兰附近，意大利的一座城市。
Oh, Milan.
噢，米兰。
Yeah.
是的。
I don't understand.
我不明白。
I think I'm going.
我想我要走了。
Stand up. Stand up, stand up.
站起来。站起来，站起来。
Trying to stand up.
试着站起来。
Please try and stand up. Do it. You can do it. Just get up on your feet. Pitch yourself up on your feet.
请试着站起来。做吧。你可以的。站到脚上去。把自己撑到脚上去。
My feet?
我的脚？
Yeah.
是的。
New York Times, November 7, 1971.
《纽约时报》，1971年11月7日。
At about 2:45 yesterday morning, a man telephoned Radio Unnameable with WBAI talk and music show, and told its moderator, Bob Fass and the station's listeners, "I'm going to commit suicide."
昨天凌晨2点45分左右，一名男子致电WBAI脱口秀音乐节目《无名电台》，告诉主持人鲍勃·法斯和电台听众：“我要自杀。”
Get up, get up.
站起来，站起来。
[MUMBLING]
[嘟囔]
The New York Telephone Company assigned more than a dozen persons to trace the call.
纽约电话公司指派了十几个人来追踪这通电话。
Stand up, stand up, stand up.
站起来，站起来，站起来。
And they determined that the call originated from the East Side.
他们确定这通电话来自东区。
Stand up.
站起来。
The police of the 104th Street Station were then notified.
104街派出所的警察接到了通知。
Get up. That's it. Get up.
站起来。就是这样。站起来。
Listeners called the station. "The man's voice sounded familiar," one said. "What are the police doing?" asked another.
听众打电话到电台。“那男人的声音听起来很熟悉，”有人说。“警察在干什么？”另一个人问。
Hello?
喂？
Mr. Fass asked his name.
法斯先生问他的名字。
What did you say your name was?
你刚才说你叫什么名字？
Stanley.
斯坦利。
Stanley what?
斯坦利什么？
Kaufman.
考夫曼。
Stanley Kaufman?
斯坦利·考夫曼？
Of course it wasn't Stanley Kaufman. Stanley Kaufman was the drama critic of the Times.
当然那不是斯坦利·考夫曼。斯坦利·考夫曼是《时报》的剧评人。
I think I know that name. Have I ever seen it published anywhere? Stanley? Stanley?
我想我知道这个名字。我曾在哪里见过发表吗？斯坦利？斯坦利？
At 6:30 AM, the police, acting on information from the telephone company, found a man lying unconscious on his bedroom floor.
早上6点30分，警方根据电话公司提供的信息，发现一名男子昏倒在卧室地板上。
Stanley?
斯坦利？
At 110 East 87th Street. His telephone was off the hook, and three empty pill bottles were at his side.
地点是东87街110号。他的电话听筒被拿掉，床边有三个空的药瓶。
Hey, Stanley! Stanley!
嘿，斯坦利！斯坦利！
The police said the man was identified by his landlady and his estranged wife as Michael Valenti, 47 years old. The man was taken to Metropolitan Hospital, where he was being kept under observation. Still unconscious yesterday afternoon.
警方称，该男子被房东和分居的妻子确认为47岁的迈克尔·瓦伦蒂。该男子被送往大都会医院，在那里接受观察。昨天下午仍处于昏迷状态。
Stanley? Stanley!
斯坦利？斯坦利！
[SNORING]
[打呼噜]
Bob finally took the call off the air and started playing this song, Hello, I Love You by The Doors. But he didn't hang up the call. He played music down the phone line instead for another three hours, in case it would help the phone company. Thought they might be listening in while tracing.
鲍勃终于把电话切断直播，开始播放这首大门乐队的《你好，我爱你》。但他没有挂断电话。他通过电话线播放了三个小时的音乐，以防能帮上电话公司。他以为他们可能在追踪时还在监听。
Bob says he did hear from Michael Valenti again, years later. Valenti called him, not on the air, just a regular phone call, to say thank you, and to tell him, "I got a job." "That's wonderful," Bob said. And this is according to Bob, Valenti says, "I want to do something for you. I'm working for Hustler Magazine. I give advice to the lovelorn. And if you want, I can get you a column where you give people advice to help them with their sexual problems." As always, Bob listened and responded candidly. He said no.
鲍勃说他多年后确实再次听到了迈克尔·瓦伦蒂的消息。瓦伦蒂打来电话，不是在直播，只是一次普通的电话，为了表示感谢，并告诉他：“我有工作了。”“那真是太棒了，”鲍勃说。而且这是根据鲍勃的说法，瓦伦蒂说：“我想为你做点什么。我在《皮条客》杂志工作。我给失意的人提供建议。如果你愿意，我可以给你一个专栏，让你给人们提供建议，帮助他们解决性问题。”像往常一样，鲍勃听了并坦率地回答。他说不。
Just a note that there are a lot of non-radio resources available to people who are in trouble, thinking of suicide. For example, there's the National Suicide Prevention Lifeline. The number is 1-800-273-8255. Thanks to Jessica Wolfson and Paul Lovelace, who made the excellent documentary Radio Unnameable. It's streaming on Amazon and iTunes.
提醒一下，对于那些遇到困难、有自杀念头的人，有很多非广播资源可以使用。例如，有全国预防自杀生命线。号码是1-800-273-8255。感谢制作了出色纪录片《无名电台》的杰西卡·沃尔夫森和保罗·洛夫莱斯。它正在亚马逊和iTunes上播放。
Coming up, the woman in charge of getting people to the streets they walk down every day, and yet don't know their names. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，是那位负责让人们找到他们每天行走却不知道名字的街道的女士。一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时，来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Sean Cole. Today's show, Who You Gonna Call? Stories of people finding the specifically perfect person to ring up in their times of need. And now we're at Act 2 of our show. Act 2, A Road By Any Other Name.
这是《美国生活》。我是肖恩·科尔。今天的节目，“你找谁？”讲述人们在需要的时候找到了那个特别完美的人来拨通电话的故事。现在我们进入节目的第二幕。第二幕，换个名字的路。
We heard about this woman in New York, who an entire community calls on the phone every day to help them get around town. She's essentially the keeper of a secret map of the city. Aaron Reiss finally secured an audience with her after meeting some of the people she helps.
我们听说纽约有这样一位女士，整个社区每天都打电话给她求助，帮他们环游城市。她基本上是城市秘密地图的守护者。亚伦·里斯在结识了一些她帮助过的人之后，终于获得了与她交谈的机会。
A while back, I moved to New York City from China, where I had just spent two years. I wanted to find a way to keep up my Chinese, so I moved into a cramped apartment on Rutgers Street with three elderly immigrants, a married couple and a single man, all in their 70s. And none of them spoke English. I would help them translate their mail. They would feed me home cooked food. We had a good thing.
不久前，我从刚呆了两年的中国搬到了纽约市。我想找个方法保持我的中文，于是搬进了一间位于罗格斯街的拥挤公寓，室友是三位70多岁的移民老人，一对已婚夫妇和一个单身汉。他们都不会说英语。我帮他们翻译邮件。他们做家常饭菜给我吃。我们相处得很愉快。
But sometimes I wouldn't understand what they were saying. The woman, for example, tended to go on at length about our neighbors and the noise from upstairs. And even though I'd pick up only a quarter of what she was saying, I would nod along, commiserating, like, totally, I know.
但有时我听不懂他们在说什么。比如那位女士，倾向于滔滔不绝地谈论我们的邻居和楼上的噪音。即使我只听懂了她说的四分之一，我也会一边点头，一边附和，就像，完全同意，我懂。
One night, we were in the kitchen talking about what we had done that day. And I was having a really hard time understanding where they had gone. They kept saying this was a place on La Zha Gai, which means dirty or garbage street. But I had never heard of that street.
一天晚上，我们在厨房聊起那天做了什么。我很难理解他们去了哪儿。他们一直说这是一个叫“拉扎盖”的地方，意思是脏乱或垃圾街。但我从没听说过这条街。
After a confusing four or five minutes, I realized that they were actually referring to the street we lived on, right where we were standing. It was just a nickname that a lot of people used for Rutgers Street. I started looking into it, and I learned the streets in Chinatown all have these Chinese names. And not just one. Streets can have four or five different names, each used by a different population in Chinatown-- longtime Toisanese and residents, recent immigrants from Fujian, Cantonese. And there are actually these different Chinese maps of the city with the same streets but different names. I started collecting them. I buy them from this guy, DiCheng, who sells them on the corner.
经过四五分钟令人困惑的交流后，我意识到他们实际上指的是我们居住的街道，就在我们站的地方。这只是很多人对罗格斯街的昵称。我开始研究它，了解到唐人街的街道都有这些中文名字。而且不止一个。街道可能有四五个不同的名字，每一个都被唐人街不同的群体使用——长期的台山人居民、刚从福建来的移民、广东人。实际上还有这些城市的不同中文地图，上面街道一样但名字不同。我开始收集它们。我从一个叫狄成的家伙那儿买，他在拐角处卖这些地图。
And there are a few people, though not many, who have to know all the names on all of the maps. Like this woman.
虽然不多，但还是有几个人必须知道所有地图上的所有名字。比如这位女士。
Hello, Lucky?
你好，幸运？
Mona is a human street name almanac, because it is her job to know. She's a dispatcher at a car service in Chinatown called Good Luck. She's in her mid-40s, lots of jewelry, no makeup, glasses. And she's always wearing this expression like, "Do I really need to be explaining this to you right now?"
莫娜是一本人形街道名称年鉴，因为这是她的工作。她是唐人街一家名为“好运”的汽车服务公司的调度员。她40多岁，戴着很多珠宝，没化妆，戴着眼镜。她总是带着一种表情，就像是：“我现在真的需要向你解释这个吗？”
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[说中文]
Right now, she's taking a call from a Cantonese customer who's looking for a car.
现在，她正接到一位寻找汽车的广东顾客的电话。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[说中文]
She's asking, "Where are you?"
她在问，“你在哪儿？”
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[说中文]
The customer just asked to get picked up on La Zha Gai, Garbage Street. Unlike me, Mona doesn't miss a beat. She knows exactly what the caller is talking about. She tells the driver to go to Rutgers, in English. Then she turns to us and explains one reason why people in Chinatown started using these nicknames in the first place.
顾客刚要求在拉扎盖，垃圾街上车。和我不同，莫娜没有错过任何一个细节。她完全知道打电话的人在说什么。她用英语告诉司机去罗格斯街。然后她转过身向我们解释唐人街人们开始使用这些昵称的一个原因。
Rutger Street, they cannot pronounce it. So that's why they gave Rutgers Street a nickname. La Zha Gai. La Zha is easy for them.
罗格斯街，他们发不出音。所以这就是为什么他们给了罗格斯街一个昵称。拉扎盖。拉扎对他们来说很容易。
To understand how this plays out, let's start with just one street, Orchard Street. First, it's got its Cantonese name. Uo Cha Gai. Sounds like "orchard," right? Then its Mandarin pronunciation. Ke Cha Jie. Then there are its translated names, which literally mean "orchard" in Mandarin and Cantonese. Guoyuan Jie and Gwoyoon Gai.
为了理解这一切是如何运作的，让我们从一条街道开始，果园街。首先，它有广东话名字。Uo Cha Gai。听起来像“orchard（果园）”，对吧？然后是它的普通话发音。Ke Cha Jie。还有它的翻译名称，在普通话和广东话里字面意思是“果园”。Guoyuan Jie 和 Gwoyoon Gai。
Then there's its nickname. Orchard used to be a main street for Jews. So depending on the level of your grandpa style racism, you might call it Jewish Street. Or, as one older guy told me, it's kind of like Cheapskate Street. There are a few versions. I'm Jewish, so don't get me started.
还有它的昵称。果园街曾经是犹太人的主街。所以根据你爷爷辈那种种族主义的程度，你可能会叫它犹太人街。或者，正如一位老人家告诉我的，这有点像“吝啬鬼街”。有几个版本。我是犹太人，所以别让我开始说这个。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[说中文]
At any given time, there are between three and five dispatchers at Good Luck's tiny Chinatown office, sitting in a row, each of them manning a few phones at once. When Mona hears Dead Person Street, she sends a car to Mulberry, which she knows is named after the funeral homes and florists on the block. When she hears Hatseller Street, she sends a car to Division Street, because, historically, well, hats.
在任何时候，好运公司那间狭小的唐人街办公室里都有三到五名调度员，并排坐着，每人同时操作几部电话。当莫娜听到“死人街”时，她会派车去桑树街，她知道那是根据街上的殡仪馆和花店命名的。当她听到“卖帽街”时，她会派车去分部街，因为，历史上，嗯，卖帽子。
There are some puzzlers, like the Kosciuszko Bridge, named after Thaddeus Kosciuszko. Everyone calls it the Yat Boon Jai Kiu, which literally means "the Japanese Guy Bridge." I asked some older ladies in Chinatown why.
还有一些难题，比如科希丘什科大桥，以塔德乌什·科希丘什科命名。大家都叫它“Yat Boon Jai Kiu”，字面意思是“日本鬼子桥”。我问了一些唐人街的老太太们为什么。
Because it has so many consonants and vowels, that it looks like a Japanese name.
因为它有太多的辅音和元音，看起来像个日本名字。
He's Polish.
他是波兰人。
Ah, Polish?
啊，波兰人？
Yeah, hello. Lucky.
是的，你好。幸运。
One day, I was visiting Mona at Good Luck, and she was on the phone with a customer, navigating between a couple of different names for the same section of East Broadway. One is like Fujianese shorthand. Hi Dong Lo, and the other is the Mandarin name, Dong Bai Lao Hui.
有一天，我去好运公司拜访莫娜，她正和一位顾客通电话，在东百老汇同一路段的几个不同名称之间切换。一个是福建话简写。Hi Dong Lo，另一个是普通话名字，Dong Bai Lao Hui。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[说中文]
Yeah, so you're going to East Broadway, am I right?
是的，所以你要去东百老汇，我没说错吧？
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[说中文]
Number 88, Hi Dong Lo, am I right?
88号，Hi Dong Lo，我没说错吧？
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[说中文]
And where in Flushing is he going?
他在法拉盛要去哪儿？
Bye-bye.
拜拜。
Then another Mandarin-speaking customer calls.
然后另一位说普通话的顾客打来了。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[说中文]
So right now where are you?
所以现在你在哪儿？
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[说中文]
She's using two different names for Canal Street, Canal Jie and Canal Lu.
她对运河街用了两个不同的名字，Canal Jie 和 Canal Lu。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[说中文]
The customer is not understanding, and is talking over Mona. Mona's like, "Slow down, listen to me," trying calmly to get on the same page. But the first time I visited Good Luck, Mona was in the front office with one phone pressed against each ear. In one receiver, she was screaming over and over again at the driver in Mandarin. "She's on Grand Street, Grand Street!" And then switching to the other receiver to try and sweet talk the English-speaking customer.
顾客听不懂，一直在打断莫娜。莫娜就像是，“慢点，听我说，”平静地试图达成共识。但我第一次去好运公司时，莫娜在前台，两耳各贴着一部电话。在一个接收器里，她用普通话对着司机大喊大叫。“她在格兰街，格兰街！”然后切换到另一个接收器，试图用好话安抚讲英语的顾客。
Just as a side note, English-speaking customers expect more coddling. Here's how Mona sounds when she talks to Chinese speakers.
顺便提一下，讲英语的顾客期望更多的娇惯。听听莫娜对讲中文的顾客说话时的声音。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[说中文]
But listen to how she is with English-speaking customers.
但听听她对讲英语的顾客是什么样。
Hi, good morning. Hi, how can I help you?
嗨，早上好。嗨，我能怎么帮你？
Anyway, that day with the two phones at her ears, Mona told me she was getting fed up with being the interpreter between two angry people.
总之，那天她两耳各贴着一部电话，莫娜告诉我她受够了在两个愤怒的人之间做翻译。
You keep telling the passenger that the driver is in front of 570 Grand Street. She don't get it. And I tell the driver you parked at the wrong location. You keep telling the passenger that the driver is in front of 570 Grand Street. She don't get it. And I tell the driver you parked on the wrong location. They both don't listen. I hate it.
你一直告诉乘客司机在格兰街570号前面。她听不懂。我告诉司机你停错了位置。你一直告诉乘客司机在格兰街570号前面。她听不懂。我告诉司机你停错了位置。他们都不听。我讨厌这样。
Why do you hate it?
你为什么讨厌这样？
I'm the middle. She have her own way. He has her own way. So I hate it in the middle.
我是中间人。她有她的方式。他有他的方式。所以我讨厌在中间。
But she doesn't quit.
但她没有辞职。
I wish I could. I wish, because once you're in this thing for a long time, you're addicted to it. It's exciting. Sometimes you yell at the people, yell at the driver. It's like the time goes fast.
我希望我能。我希望，因为一旦你在这行做了很长时间，你就上瘾了。这很刺激。有时你对人吼，对司机吼。就像时间过得很快。
A lot of people depend on Mona, people who can't just hail a cab or call an Uber and describe to a non-Chinese driver where they want to go. And even if they could, there's the name trouble. Your average New York cabbie probably can't chart a course for 24 Dead Person Street, or 54 Monkey Street. For those people, there are just a few places to turn for help, a handful of car companies and dispatchers like Mona.
很多人依赖莫娜，那些不能直接拦出租车或叫优步并向不会中文的司机描述他们想去哪儿的人。即使他们能，还有名字的问题。你的普通纽约出租车司机可能无法为“死人街24号”或“猴子街54号”规划路线。对于这些人来说，只有几个求助的地方，少数几家汽车公司和像莫娜这样的调度员。
And customers are grateful. On Chinese New Year, old ladies head over to Good Luck's office on Ludlow Street. They hand over red envelopes with a few dollars inside, her name written at the top. "For Mona."
顾客们很感激。农历新年时，老太太们会前往位于勒德洛街的好运公司办公室。她们递上里面装有几美元的红色信封，上面写着她的名字。“给莫娜。”
Act 3, Ode To Joy. There's this thing President Trump used to say before he got elected. It was part of his regular stump speech, kind of a rallying cry.
第三幕，欢乐颂。特朗普总统在当选前常说一句话。那是他常规竞选演讲的一部分，类似于一种集结号。
We're gonna start winning again. We're gonna win so much, you may even get tired of winning! And you'll say, "Please, please, it's too much winning. We can't take it anymore. Mr. President, it's too much!"
我们要开始重新赢了。我们要赢这么多，你可能会厌倦赢！然后你会说，“求求你，求求你，赢太多了。我们受不了了。总统先生，太多了！”
And without going into the merits of whether the president is getting tired of too much winning, or whether it is in fact even possible to get tired of too much winning, our program today deals in some ways with advice. And I do think it's possible to get tired of too much advice, for someone to offer so much good advice that's so perfectly suited to you that at some point you decide it just pains you to hear it.
而不去讨论总统是否厌倦了赢太多，或者是否真的有可能厌倦赢太多，我们今天的节目在某种程度上是关于建议的。我确实认为，人是有可能厌倦太多的建议的，以至于有人提供那么多完全适合你的好建议，到某个点你决定听了反而感到痛苦。
The regular host of our show, Ira Glass, heard of that happening to a friend of his. Here's Ira.
我们节目的主持人艾拉·格拉斯听说了他的一位朋友发生了这种情况。这是艾拉。
The friend is my friend Lucy. And the person who gave her such good advice was not me. Which-- OK, I'm not hurt by that. I personally think the advice that Lucy and I give each other is excellent. Lucy can think what she wants. When it comes to advice, I know that the person who's advice has been a consistent north star in Lucy's life for like 15 years now is a professional advice giver, a psychologist on a call-in radio show who gives advice over the air-- Dr. Joy Browne.
这位朋友是我的朋友露西。给她这样好建议的人不是我。这——好吧，我没受伤。我个人认为露西和我互相给的建议都很棒。露西想怎么想就怎么想。说到建议，我知道在露西生命中一直是一颗北极星的建议，那个人是专业的建议给予者，一档广播电台热线节目的心理学家，在电波中给予建议——乔伊·布朗博士。
Lucy says she likes Dr. Joy Browne because, unlike some other radio psychologists that she's listened to in the past, Dr. Joy Browne doesn't smack her callers over the head with a frying pan and tell them what they're doing is wrong. Joy Browne is kind but deeply pragmatic. There's a whole raft of principles and mottos that come up over and over, all of which Lucy has internalized. Like, "Stupid and cheerful."
露西说她喜欢乔伊·布朗博士，因为不像她过去听过的其他广播心理学家，乔伊·布朗博士不会用平底锅拍打听众的脑袋告诉他们做错了什么。乔伊·布朗和蔼但深具实用主义精神。有一整套原则和格言不断出现，所有这些露西都内化了。比如，“愚蠢且快乐”。
If somebody is trying to engage you in some sort of passive aggressive issue, you just try to be as stupid and cheerful as possible. So like, if somebody comes into your kitchen and is like, "Oh, you're painting it this color?" You just go like, "Yup. Isn't it great?"
如果有人试图让你陷入某种被动攻击的问题中，你只要尽量表现得愚蠢且快乐就行了。所以，如果有人走进你的厨房说，“噢，你把它漆成这个颜色？”你只要回答，“是啊。不是很好吗？”
Oh.
噢。
You know? Stupid and cheerful. It really works.
你知道吗？愚蠢且快乐。这真的很管用。
My dear, this is one of those times that you're going to have to be stupid and cheerful.
亲爱的，这是你不得不表现得愚蠢且快乐的时刻之一。
This, of course, is the doctor herself, talking to a 23-year-old woman named Michelle, who lives with her mom, who explains to Dr. Joy Browne that she's ready to move out.
这当然是医生本人，正在和一个名叫米歇尔的23岁女子交谈，她和母亲住在一起，她向乔伊·布朗博士解释说她准备搬出去了。
Yes, the difficulty is, is that she suffers from mental illness, and she is severely depressed, and she gets verbally abusive, and she yells, and I need to leave.
是的，困难在于，她患有精神疾病，而且严重抑郁，她会语言虐待，她大喊大叫，我需要离开。
OK, how old is mom?
OK，妈妈多大？
Dr. Joy Browne runs through a quick series of questions and ascertains that the mom is 55, not working, single, under therapist care, on meds. Then she pivots to her advice-- stupid and cheerful.
乔伊·布朗博士进行了一系列快速提问，确认妈妈55岁，没工作，单身，在接受治疗，服用药物。然后她转换话题到她的建议——愚蠢且快乐。
Equal emphasis on stupid and cheerful. If you go in to your mom, and say, "Mom, I know this is going to really upset you, but it's time for me to leave," if you deal with the subtext, "You're abandoning me. I can't believe you're doing this," you're lost, and so is she. It's not like it benefits either of you. So we're not going to do that. Just be stupid and cheerful.
愚蠢和快乐重点同样强调。如果你去找你妈说，“妈，我知道这会让你很难过，但该是我离开的时候了，”如果你处理的是潜台词，“你在抛弃我。我不敢相信你在做这种事，”你就输了，她也一样。这对你们俩都没好处。所以我们不那样做。只要愚蠢且快乐。
OK.
好的。
What you need to say is, "Mom, you know what? I found this great apartment. Will you come and help me find some furniture?" And what you're going to have to do is decide that you're going to win the Meryl Streep award for Brooklyn, all right? And you're going to say, "Mom, I'm so excited." And you're going to have to be stupid about the fact that this may be traumatic for her. But it's not your responsibility to take care of your mom at this stage in your life.
你需要说的是，“妈，你知道吗？我找了个很棒的公寓。你能来帮我找点家具吗？”而你需要做的是决定你将赢得布鲁克林的梅丽尔·斯特里普奖，好吗？你要说，“妈，我太兴奋了。”你必须对这对她可能是创伤性事实装傻。但在你人生的这个阶段，照顾你妈妈不是你的责任。
You can show up on the phone with whatever kind of messy, emotional or non-emotional, trivial or not trivial problem. And you hand her the Rubik's cube of that, and she would ask a few questions, and hand it back to all put together with all the colors on the right side.
你可以带着任何混乱、情绪化或非情绪化、琐碎或不琐碎的问题出现在电话里。把问题的魔方交给她，她会问几个问题，然后把它重新组合好，所有的颜色都放在正确的一面交还给你。
Mom's gotta learn to take care of herself.
妈妈得学会照顾自己。
OK.
好的。
All righty? Stupid, honey. Stupid and cheerful, stupid and cheerful, stupid and cheerful. All right?
好吗？愚蠢，亲爱的。愚蠢且快乐，愚蠢且快乐，愚蠢且快乐。好吗？
All right.
好的。
Lucy likes how encouraging Dr. Joy Browne always is, and kind of good humored. And she's listened to her for thousands of hours, first on the radio, then on podcast. The show is three hours every day. Now Dr. Joy Browne has such a hold over Lucy's thinking and over her heart that Lucy will say things like--
露西喜欢乔伊·布朗博士总是那么鼓舞人心，而且挺幽默的。她听了她几千个小时，先是在收音机里，后来是在播客上。这个节目每天三个小时。现在乔伊·布朗博士对露西的思想和内心有着如此大的掌控力，以至于露西会说出这样的话——
Well, you know, we didn't always agree on everything, but mostly.
嗯，你知道，我们并不总是在所有事情上达成一致，但大部分时候是。
The phrase "we didn't agree about everything" implies that she was in on this relationship too.
“我们并不总是在所有事情上达成一致”这句话暗示她也参与了这段关系。
Well, sort of. Although we didn't agree on everything. You know, she had some beliefs that I didn't believe in.
嗯，算是吧。虽然我们并不在所有事情上达成一致。你知道，她有一些信仰，我不相信。
No, again, there's no "we."
不，再说一次，没有“我们”。
I guess you're right.
我想你说得对。
The look in your face, I said that and your feelings looked really hurt, and I suddenly felt sort of bad.
看你的脸，我说了那句话，你的情绪看起来真的很受伤，我突然觉得有点不好。
No, don't feel bad. I mean, I guess my relationship with Dr. Joy Browne is at the intersection of incredibly lighthearted and really, really deep-seated and emotional, for me. Like a radio call-in show psychologist, it's a low stakes, right? Except, it's not really. Because people call in with real problems. And so with her, the relationship sits right in the middle of being kind of like a joke and being like a super serious part of my psyche. You know?
不，别觉得不好。我是说，我想我和乔伊·布朗博士的关系处于极其轻松和非常、非常深刻的情感之间的交汇点。像广播热线心理学家，风险很低，对吧？除了，并不是真的。因为人们打进电话来诉说真正的问题。所以对于她，这种关系恰好处于像个笑话和像我心理极其严肃的一部分之间的中间地带。你知道吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Lucy is so in tune with what Dr. Joy Browne would say in any situation that sometimes when friends and family turn to her for advice, she just doles out whatever she thinks Dr. Joy Browne would say. Like, when her aunt was in a relationship where she was not getting what she wanted, very unhappy, feeling awful.
露西对乔伊·布朗博士在任何情况下会说什么非常了解，以至于有时当朋友和家人向她寻求建议时，她只是分发她认为乔伊·布朗博士会说的话。比如，当她的阿姨处于一段她没得到想要的东西、非常不开心、感觉糟糕的关系中时。
And I said to her, think about what the relationship is like now. Think if you knew you were never going to get any more than this, and you were never going to get any less than this out of the situation. Would you stay or go? And if you would go, how long would you wait before you go? That's straight up Dr. Joy Browne.
我对她说，想想现在的关系是什么样。想想如果你知道你永远得不到比这更多，也永远不会得到比这更少。你会留下还是走？如果你会走，你会等多久才走？那是纯粹的乔伊·布朗博士风格。
Mhm.
嗯。
And my aunt thought that that was really stellar advice, and it really helped her. And then I had to admit to her that I had gotten it from someone else. But she was still into it.
我阿姨认为那是很棒的建议，它真的帮到了她。然后我不得不承认我是从别人那儿得到的。但她依然觉得很受用。
Lucy's called Dr. Joy Browne for advice a half dozen times over the years. She called her for advice the first time when she was just 21, after moving in with her boyfriend. She had never lived with a boyfriend before, and it was going badly. And she did have friends she could turn to for advice, and she could call her mom, who she's really close to. But she didn't want to admit to anybody that she knew that things were going so poorly. Dr. Joy Browne was the perfect anonymous friend.
这些年来，露西打给乔伊·布朗博士寻求过半打次建议。她第一次打电话寻求建议时才21岁，在和男朋友同居之后。她以前从未和男朋友同居过，情况很糟糕。她确实有朋友可以寻求建议，也可以打电话给和她很亲近的妈妈。但她不想向任何人承认她知道事情变得这么糟糕。乔伊·布朗博士是完美的匿名朋友。
This phone call was so long ago that we weren't able to find recordings of it. Lucy says she was sitting on the floor in the hallway of the little apartment in North Carolina when she phoned.
这通电话是很久以前打的，我们找不到录音了。露西说打电话时她正坐在北卡罗来纳州那个小公寓门厅的地板上。
You're hearing the radio show in the phone, because you have talked to the screener. You've told them your question. And then you have to wait until she says your name.
你在电话里听到的是广播节目，因为你和筛选员谈过了。你告诉他们你的问题。然后你得等到她说出你的名字。
Yeah, what's that like?
是啊，那是什么感觉？
It's incredibly nerve-wracking and, you know, palms sweating, and thinking about hanging up, and just wondering when it's going to happen. She could say your name at any time. And then she does. She says "Lucy, what's your question?" And I describe my situation, and I think that I cried a little bit. That's my memory.
非常令人紧张，你知道，手心出汗，想着要不要挂断，只是想知道什么时候会发生。她可能随时说出你的名字。然后她说了。她说“露西，你的问题是什么？”我描述了我的情况，我想我哭了一点。这是我的记忆。
What was her advice?
她的建议是什么？
Her advice was to leave the relationship right then.
她的建议是立刻离开那段关系。
How many minutes did you talk to her before she said that? Like, was it 10, 5?
她在说那个之前和你聊了几分钟？比如，是10分钟，5分钟？
No, maybe like 2 and 1/2.
不，大概2分半钟。
2 and 1/2 minutes?
2分半钟？
Yeah.
是的。
Wow, that's a really sobering thing, that you could talk to a stranger for 2 and 1/2 minutes, and they're just like, "Yeah, got it. OK, leave him."
哇，这是一个令人清醒的事情，你可以和一个陌生人聊2分半钟，他们就像，“是的，明白了。OK，离开他。”
Yeah, she said leave. And she said, get your own apartment, and start your own life there, and just get out of the situation.
是的，她说离开。她说，找你自己的公寓，在那里开始你自己的生活，离开那种境地。
Did you think it was good advice?
你觉得这是个好建议吗？
It was not what I wanted to hear. I wanted to be told how to fix it, you know? That advice to leave seemed completely impossible.
这不是我想听到的。我想被告知怎么修复它，你知道吗？那种离开的建议看起来完全不可能。
How long did it take for you to leave?
你花了多久才离开？
It took about a year.
花了大约一年。
In retrospect, do you think you should have taken the advice when she gave it to you?
回顾过去，你认为你应该在她给出建议时就采纳吗？
Yes
是的。
Why call in to an advice show if you're not going to take the advice?
如果不想听取建议，为什么要打进建议节目？
I think, in a way, my mind went blank, and I was just shaken by her response. I just thought, this person who I've come to know and trust so much? I don't know. I was pretty shocked that she told me I should leave.
我想，在某种程度上，我的大脑一片空白，被她的回应震惊了。我只是想，这个我已经变得如此了解和信任的人？我不知道。我被她告诉我应该离开感到非常震惊。
Lucy called once for advice about dealing with her parents, and once for advice about a situation with her sister. Both times she took the advice, and says it went great. One of her professors was dying. She wanted to write him a letter saying some nice things, but wasn't sure that somebody would want to get a letter saying "I hear you're dying, and so I wrote you this letter." Dr. Joy Browne told her to send the letter. Of course send it. It's kindness. Which she did.
露西曾有一次打电话寻求处理父母问题的建议，还有一次关于和姐姐的关系问题。两次她都听从了建议，并说效果很好。她的一位教授快去世了。她想写一封信告诉他一些好话，但又不确定别人想不想收到一封信说“听说你快死了，所以我写了这封信”。乔伊·布朗博士告诉她寄那封信。当然寄。这是善良。她照做了。
And something else happened on that call that Lucy loved.
而且那次通话还发生了露西很喜欢的一件事。
She called me "cookie" during that call, I remember. Which is something that she called a lot of people from time to time. So it was a thrill to me.
记得那次通话中她叫我“饼干”。那是她时不时称呼很多人的称呼。所以对我来说那是一种激动。
But did she only call them cookie if she liked them?
但如果她喜欢他们，她才会叫他们饼干吗？
I think it was an affectionate term.
我觉得那是个亲昵的称呼。
It sounds pretty affectionate.
听起来挺亲昵的。
Yeah, I mean, cookies are great.
是啊，我是说，饼干很棒。
Noted.
记下了。
This went on for years. Lucy listened to Dr. Joy Browne for hours every day, and occasionally phoning her up for advice. And then her whole situation with Dr. Joy Browne took a turn. This happened in just the last few years, during the time that Lucy and I had been friends. Lucy was having some troubles, and was really pretty miserable. And she could have called Dr. Joy Browne for advice, but she never did.
这种情况持续了几年。露西每天听乔伊·布朗博士好几个小时，偶尔打电话寻求建议。然后她和乔伊·布朗博士的整个情况发生了转变。这发生在过去几年里，在露西和我成为朋友的那段时间。露西遇到了一些麻烦，非常悲惨。她本可以打给乔伊·布朗博士寻求建议，但她从没打。
No, actually, for the last few years, I had not been listening to her. I stopped listening to her, in large part because I got into several relationship situations in a row that I knew that she would totally not approve of.
不，事实上，过去几年，我一直没听她的。我停止听她的，很大程度上是因为我连续陷入了几段我知道她绝对不会赞成的关系。
One of them is somebody who is possessive and not so nice to her. One was somebody married, separated but married.
其中一个是占有欲强且对她不太好的人。一个是已婚的，分居但已婚的人。
And I think it became too embarrassing for me to listen to her, the way that I used to.
我觉得我无法像过去那样听她说话，这对我来说太尴尬了。
You mean embarrassing like you feel like you couldn't be in her presence because you knew what she would think of what you were doing?
你的意思是尴尬，就像你觉得你无法出现在她面前，因为你知道她会怎么看你的所作所为？
Yeah.
是的。
You felt like you knew her that well?
你觉得你那么了解她？
Yeah, I felt like if I had called her with a problem about one of these relationships, we wouldn't have even gotten to my problem I was having. She would have, right off the bat, said well, the problem here is that you're not following the One Year Rule. She had this thing called the One Year Rule.
是的，我觉得如果我把这些关系中遇到的问题告诉她，我们甚至不会聊到我的问题。她会直接说，嗯，这里的问题是你没遵循“一年规则”。她有那个叫“一年规则”的东西。
Yeah, well, I keep telling people you need to go through a year by yourself after the breakup of an important relationship, whether it's divorce or death.
是的，嗯，我一直告诉人们，在重要关系破裂后，你需要独自度过一年，无论是离婚还是死亡。
This is Dr. Joy Browne explaining the One Year Rule to a caller.
这是乔伊·布朗博士向听众解释一年规则。
Because you'll make different decisions based on need than you will on want. And when you're feeling really lonely and really sad, you'll succumb to things that, if you're feeling better about yourself, you wouldn't do.
因为你会基于需求而不是想要做出不同的决定。当你感到非常孤独和悲伤时，你会屈服于那些如果你自我感觉更好就不会做的事情。
And this is a caller named Angela who phoned to thank Dr. Browne for the One Year Rule.
这是一位名叫安吉拉的听众，打电话感谢布朗博士的一年规则。
You know, Dr. Joy, in the beginning, I was thinking Dr. Joy is crazy. One year? That's a long time.
你知道，乔伊博士，起初我在想乔伊博士疯了。一年？那是很长的时间。
Yeah.
是啊。
But no, it is the greatest time I've been having all these days.
但不，这是我这些天来度过的最棒的时光。
Well, that's great. And you're probably a much happier person than you were a year ago, which means that you're going to be much more date-able, and you'll find somebody who is more wonderful than you would have a year ago. So that's great.
我正要重新开始听，但我只是想念她了。就像，我只错过了她两天。那一周她还在做节目。据所知她完全健康。我真的很悲伤。
Yes, I am super super duper happy! Thank you very much, and God bless you.
是的，我超级超级无敌快乐！非常感谢你，上帝保佑你。
So Lucy knew the score. She hadn't obeyed the One Year Rule. The people she was with hadn't either. And she saw the basic wisdom of the doctor's One Year Rule.
所以露西懂这些。她没遵守一年规则。和她在一起的人也没遵守。她也看到了医生一年规则的基本智慧。
And I knew that she would have said like "No, no, no. This is not going to work. You've got to get out of it." I think it became a lot less fun for me to listen to her because I knew that I was in a mess, you know? And I knew that if I had really taken her advice, I wouldn't be in that mess.
我知道她会说，“不，不，不。这不会奏效。你必须离开。”我觉得我听她的话变得没那么有趣了，因为我知道我陷入了混乱，你知道吗？而且我知道如果我真的采纳了她的建议，我也不会陷入那种混乱。
Lucy was like a sinner who doesn't like stepping foot in church, because it reminds 'em just how far they'd fallen. So she stayed away. And then, finally, not long ago, Lucy got out of that last relationship. She was single again. And it only took a day or two after that.
露西就像一个不喜欢走进教堂的罪人，因为它提醒他们跌得有多深。所以她保持距离。然后，终于，不久前，露西结束了最后那段关系。她又单身了。这只花了一两天时间。
And I was in a taxi, and I suddenly thought, "I'm going to look up Dr. Joy Browne's podcast, and I'm going to start listening again.
我正坐在出租车里，突然想到，“我要去查乔伊·布朗博士的播客，我要重新开始听。”
Right, because finally you could. Because you felt like you wouldn't feel this guilt.
对，因为终于可以了。因为你觉得你不会感到这种内疚。
Yeah, I had a clean slate.
是的，我有一张干净的名单。
Mhm.
嗯。
So I looked her up, and I was totally shocked and horrified to find that she had just died two days before, very suddenly. And I was really sad, and really panicked. Like, no, no, no, wait, wait, wait. I need to-- like, what? No, no, no. I need to listen to your show. You can't die.
所以我查了她，我很震惊和恐怖地发现她在两天前刚刚去世了，非常突然。我很悲伤，也非常恐慌。就像，不，不，不，等等，等等，等等。我需要——比如，什么？不，不，不。我需要听你的节目。你不能死。
I just was going to start listening again, and I just missed her. Like, I just missed her by two days. She was doing her show that week. She was totally well, and as far as anyone knew. And I was really sad.
我本来正打算重新开始听，结果却错过了她。就差了两天。那周她还在做节目。据大家所知，她当时一切都好。我真的很难过。
How long had you not listened to her?
你有多久没听她的节目了？
Probably-- maybe five years.
大概——也许五年。
Do you feel like you let her down?
你觉得你让她失望了吗？
Yeah, I felt like I'd jumped ship, and taken her for granted, and thought she would be there when I resurfaced from whatever kind of messy mess I had gotten myself into. You know that thing that people say, "When I just like make enough money, then I'll get my life together, when I just lose enough weight, then I'll get my life together." And I think in the period where I stopped listening to her, I was thinking like, "Once I sort all this out, I'll get back to listening to Dr. Joy and I'll resurface as the person I was before, once I clean up this mess." But I never did. And then, when I resurfaced, she was gone.
是的，我觉得我跳船了，认为她是理所当然的，认为当我从我陷入的某种混乱中浮出水面时，她会在那里。你知道人们常说的，“当我赚够钱了，我就整理好生活，当我减够肥了，我就整理好生活。”我觉得在我停止听她节目的那段时间，我一直在想，“一旦我处理好所有这些，我就回去听乔伊博士的节目，我会作为以前的我浮出水面，一旦我清理完这些混乱。”但我从没这样做过。然后，当我浮出水面时，她走了。
It made her totally re-evaluate her relationship with Dr. Joy Browne. All those years she thought, the two of them so in agreement. She felt so close to her. It made her realize, oh, maybe she was just kidding herself.
这让她完全重新评估了她与乔伊·布朗博士的关系。这些年来她以为，她们两人非常一致。她感觉离她那么近。这让她意识到，噢，也许她只是在自欺欺人。
I guess it does use to listen thinking people would call in, and they'd give their situation, and I'd just think, "Oh boy, here's the problem with what you're saying. I know what she's going to say." And then she would say it, and I was sitting back like, "Dr. Joy and I, we know the rules, and that's not going to work."
我想她过去常听着想人们会打进来，他们会说出他们的情况，我就会想，“噢伙计，你说的这个有问题。我知道她会说什么。”然后她就会说出来，我坐着像是，“乔伊博士和我，我们知道规则，那行不通。”
Yeah. And it's like you and her against the losers. But then you were going like, "Oh, wait a second. No, I'm one of the losers."
是啊。就像你和她对抗那些输家。但然后你又像是，“噢，等一下。不，我也是那些输家之一。”
Well, I mean, losers, she had a warm heart.
我是说，输家，她有一颗温暖的心。
She wouldn't use that word. No, but you know what I'm saying.
她不会用那个词。不，但你知道我说的是什么。
They were like the people who were astray. And you know, I had a lot of big ideas about how I had it together. And I was doing it wrong too. And even though I knew better, even though I used to sit there, imagining myself near Dr. Joy Browne, I know what she would say, but I would feel better if she were here to say it.
他们就像那些误入歧途的人。你知道，我有很多关于我如何整理好生活的宏大想法。我以前也做错了。尽管我知道得更好，尽管我曾坐在那儿，想象自己就在乔伊·布朗博士附近，我知道她会说什么，但如果她在这儿说出来，我会感觉更好。
Yeah. There's a thing that people say to each other in movies that I've never, ever in my life had an impulse to say to somebody, but I do now. And that is, "Well, you carry her inside you."
是啊。电影里人们常说一句话，我这辈子从来没有冲动对别人说过，但现在有了。那就是，“嗯，你把你携带在内心。”
Um, well, what does the other person in the movie say, then?
嗯，那电影里的另一个人会说什么呢？
Usually, they're really moved.
通常，他们真的很感动。
Oh, well.
噢，好吧。
In the movies! Hold on for a second. This is the kind of music that we play in the movie. Hold on. Stay right there.
在电影里！等一下。这是我们电影里播放的那种音乐。等一下。待在那儿别动。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[播放音乐]
It's going to be this kind of music. I'm going to say it to you again. Lucy, even though she's gone, you don't have to feel bad, because you carry her inside you.
会是这种音乐。我再对你说一次。露西，即使她走了，你也不必感到不好，因为你把你携带在内心。
And then I would just say, "I guess you're right."
然后我会回答，“我想你是对的。”
There you go.
就是这样。
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
That was excellent line-reading.
那是极好的台词朗读。
Ira Glass. That kid's got talent, right?
艾拉·格拉斯。那孩子有天赋，对吧？
Our program was produced today by Stephanie Foo. Our staff includes Elna Baker, Elise Bergerson, Susan Burton, Dana Chivvis, Whitney Dangerfield, Neil Drumming, Kimberly Henderson, David Kestenbaum, Chana Joffe-Walt, Seth Lind, Jonathan Menjivar, BA Parker, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our senior producer is Brian Reed.
我们的节目今天由斯蒂芬妮·傅制作。我们的员工包括埃尔娜·贝克、爱丽丝·伯格森、苏珊·伯顿、达纳·齐维斯、惠特尼·丹格菲尔德、尼尔·德拉明、金伯利·亨德森、大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、赛斯·林德、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、BA帕克、克里斯托弗·斯维塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。我们的高级制作人是布莱恩·里德。
Special thanks to Eric Mennel, Louisa Gao, Bing Yen, Hamilton Madison House City Hall Senior Center, Judy Lei, Ya Yun Teng, and the Museum of Chinese in America, Joo Wai Foo, Chuck Leung, and Michael Harrison. Research help from Michelle Harris and Lu Fong.
特别感谢埃里克·门内尔、路易莎·高、冰燕、汉密尔顿麦迪逊之家市政厅老年中心、朱迪·雷、雅云腾和美国华人博物馆、朱伟傅、查克·梁和迈克尔·哈里森。研究帮助来自米歇尔·哈里斯和卢芳。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Extra special thanks this week to my boss, Ira Glass. I assured Ira before he left. I was like, "Absolutely, go away this week. It's fine. We'll air a re-run."
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交易所）传送到公共广播电台。这周给我的老板艾拉·格拉斯特别感谢。我出发前向艾拉保证。我说，“当然，这周离开吧。没关系。我们会播重播。”
With all due respect, I think you're trying to trick me.
恕我直言，我认为你在耍我。
I'm Sean Cole. Call your mom, and join us next week for more stories of This American Life.
我是肖恩·科尔。给妈妈打个电话，下周加入我们收听更多《美国生活》的故事。